this is still part of 100 wonders the
October edition north of Rome in the
woods of Italy there are monsters
lurking we tend to think of urban
exploration as a relatively modern
affair but it has parallels that go back
much farther than that interested
curious writers and artists tend to seek
out the odd and unusual in the case of
salvador dali he found something truly
spectacular in 1938 he came across what
the locals called the park Oh des monts
tree or the park of monster the garden
of monsters was commissioned in 1552
by Prince Pierre Francesco Orsini and he
didn't Commission this to be beautiful
or to impress you he wanted to shock you
the prince was returning from a brutal
war he'd see his best friend die and
then he'd been captured himself and held
ransom for over three years when he was
finally released and got home to his
beloved wife she died shortly thereafter
one thought is that he commissioned the
park of monsters as a way to deal with
the immense grief that came along with
all of this tragedy an inscription at
the entrance of the park says those who
do not visit this place with raised
eyebrows and pursed lips will fail to
admire the seven wonders of the world he
was like this place is nuts and if
you're not into it then nothing's gonna
flow your boat in this park is a giant
elephant lifting a Roman soldier there
is a house purposely made to slant in a
strange and disorienting lead two giants
ripping each other apart
a sculpture of a giant fish with a
little world and a castle on top and the
idea is the fish is time itself and it
Dwarfs everything else these are
creatures from beyond space and time
long before Lovecraft it's all ancient
monsters it's a bestiary and of course
most captivating of all is the noir
his head of Orcas god of the underworld
his mall wide and gaping begging for you
to step inside an orca says upper lip is
the inscription all thoughts fly which
is a theme throughout the gardens this
notion that basically you will be
rendered senseless by the aesthetic
experience also as a kind of a trick
it's a go whispering gallery so if you
stand in a certain place people at the
bottom of the steps can hear you speak
so you could go in there and be like
this is orcas go away once the Prince
died in the 1580s no more work was done
in the park and by the 1800s and 1900s
it had fallen entirely into disrepair
and become basically a spooky Legend for
the locals so the entire park has this
kind of incredible surrealist feel to it
which is why when Dali discovered it or
rediscovered it he was like this is my
jam he made a short film about it it
inspired a painting of his he sort of
brought it back into public
consciousness and it was finally
restored in the 1950s and has gone on to
become well visited attraction we don't
have any records of what the prince's
mind state was when he built the park of
monsters and whether he was working
through his grief or simply just wanted
to do something that was different from
the fancy schmancy sculptures going on
around him he really created a unique
destination and although it may be
shrouded in mystery Salvador Dali
certainly knew it was special when he
stumbled upon it more videos here and
subscribe here I want to thank youtuber
Eddie girge thank you for watching the
show thank you for guessing that is it
was in fact a moose skeleton we have an
entire moose skeleton here in the office
one day we will construct it and thank
you for suggesting such a great 101 or
to do I love this place I was thrilled
to put it into the 100 Wonders it
belongs there so thank you again so much
for that suggestion